some local students are stepping up to  make sure kids in need have the tools to  succeed  today the jobs for nevada's graduates  group teamed up with nonprofit  project 150 to host a backpack donation  drive  hundreds of backpacks filled with school  supplies hygiene items and basic goods  were handed out to homeless and  disadvantaged youth come out here and  let students know that we're  part of their community to support them  to get them through high school  is a great opportunity and we love  working with the high school students  and supporting them in their endeavors  too the jobs for nevada's graduates  group is made up of students from mohave  high school  today's drive was part of a series of  projects called lifting our voices for  equity love project as part of the  project to serve  local kids in need